al
みなさんこんにちは
帝王義塾女子高校2年のトイ煎じです
絵を描くことを私にとって言葉が悪いの表現集
まあ受けない頃魅力が欲しくて小指を書いたそうです
女子校では演劇界などの矜持で2位ベースを担当したり色々なオーケストラで楽器を
聞いたりポスターを作ったり
bs へとデザインと音楽演奏作曲
裏方の相対性ば数日々を送っています
中等部女子校と進みず美術と音楽そして人が
中ていると感じることが多くなりました
今まで今これからすべてはつながっているそして私らしいつながりについて話したいと
思います
まずは私自身について少しお話しましょう
小さい頃私はとても病気にかかりやすく
寒い日にも外に出たり講演や停車に少し頂けすぐに病気になり
一気に重症化していった水症状を残してしまう
いつも病院に入院してばかりいる調査くさいすのこどこでした
コミュニケーションがあるのは家族だけ
それに私は4歳になってもカイオウすることがほかの子と違ってほとんどできなかった
ので
私は必死に l 意思を伝えようとしていました
魅力が欲しくなった時は叫んたりわめいたりするわけでもなく
哺乳瓶の絵を書いていたのです
では私にとってそれこそそのまま生きる手段でした
中根少しずつ体も丈夫になり私は保育園理事日を過ごすようになりました
長い時間あまり話したこともなかった同年代の子どもたちと共に過ごす生活
それは私にとってすごく大きなストレスになりました
私が当時大好きだったの一つはいろんな図鑑を読み尽くすことと絵を書くことと
そして
エジプト文明の黄金のマスクなどのデザインを正した空研究して
年度いこ蔵をつくることでした
家にこもってばかりの私の趣味は体を動かすのが大好きなよう歳児という常識から
あまりにも外れたものでした
温泉周りにもなじむことができず
周りの子達と市民がはず変わってるというの真下に言われるちょっと寂しい日々おめ
ました
またその頃にピアノとヴァイオリンを習い始めました
もしに練習しているとひとりぽっちの作家話したが理科が和らぎをな気がしました
ただまだこの頃はその必死にやってる感じではなんという
親としてもあくまでも許容としてならてだけのすごいあったです
ようです
そんな中私は小学校に入りました
パイプが苦手でいつもえばかり書いて私に担任の先生をとても優しくしてくださいまし
た
ある日その先生は私は知らないうちに
ってに2が工作の授業で解体を区の改革部に出していたことが分かりました
それも分かったのは受賞した後の話です
小学校1年生の頃のこの絵です
いつも時間でしか読んだことがなくてやっと家の中で飼うことができた
アゲハ蝶の成長した姿です
朝礼でいきなり校長先生に呼ばれて広い校庭の真ん中には超レーダーに呼ばれてみんな
の前
上昇されて拍手される
そんな体験を始めてねとてもうれしかったことを鮮明に覚えています
人に褒められる嬉しさを知った瞬間です
これが私が多くの音楽美術の今空にできっかけになりました
ん
音楽のコンクリは先生からしました
ここで後僕のコンクリート美術は今回の自覚をしてみたいと思います
音楽のコンクールは生成過去の金買いにいきましょうと半ば強制的に勧められます
毎日毎日長いしか停車します
そう時間から5時間が当たり前10時間乗って下皿です
私はかなり練習嫌いでいかに短くさせるかいかに効率的にそのせいかばっかり考えて
ましたか
上手な下になればなるほど当然たくさん
無人練習します
女性から本番前長い間とてもプレッシャーがかかり大変です
部材でもまた緊張します
他の出場者が全員自分より情勢に聞こえます
そしてその日のうちに結果が帰ってて授賞式があります
会場ではだいたい笑ったりの話です
hobio もので音というだいたい演奏する機会が与えられます
私の場合どんな機会をいただいたかというと
例えば
ピアノみなとみらいホールで吐かせていただいたいっ
梅雨位のサントリーゴールで加瀬いただいたり
中学2年の時にオーケストラと免税ストーンの場合り狂騒曲というとても有名な曲を
そうでしかせていただいたい
推しの音楽大学に行っ瞬間レッスンに行かせていただいたいっ
どれもなかなかできない大変です
当時音楽のコンクールは私にとって楽しいと言う
どちらかというと苦痛がう
多かったような気がします
今振り返るとなかなか素晴らしいターキーをさせてもらうということに気づきました
ちなみに音楽の今回はだいたいよ say 落ちをすると何が問題かわかりますか
ん
大大大額のと一冊です
とても悔しいのでだいたいそれら全部今も大切にしています
ここでへのコンクリの場合を見てみましょう
さっきお話ししたように小学校の先生が自分が知らないうちに勝手に出していた
なんてことなりますが
だいたいは自分から探します
チップ音楽の場合と違って先制
私どうされることはなく100%自分の意思とアイデアだけで開きます
たりにもなりにも言われない
と言うには
誰にも表最大10%おります
しかし中というのは伏在先生もおっしゃっていた通りいっ
自分に責任を干すということです
あらぬ方向には向かってしまっても誰も止めてくれる人はいないのです
水は絵のコンクールの一番大切なことだと思います
応募者は生た頃に審査結果をきますちょっと悲しいですが自分が解体はほとんどの場合
返却してもらえません
そして著作権向こうがにわたってしまいます
その顔にいろいろな場所で私の名前とともに多くの方に絵を見たいいただくことができ
ます
例えば
moe 美術館というところで私は金賞をいただいたのですがその上はとジョイずっと
飾っていただくことができました
その時の体験は私は最初は半信半疑だったんですがいざ見に行ってみると本当に飾られ
ていてとてもうれしかったんです
授賞式の後はだいたい豪華なお食事とお酒の出るパーティーになります
私はまだ2000年ですのでお酒を羨ましそうに見つめながら重曹飲んでいろんな方と
お話します
震災の主催者も主唱者もたくさん話し機会があって面白い
どちらにしても私にしては人に褒めていただいたりいろんな人と話せたりという期間
いただける絶好のチャンスです
こんな比較をしてみましたけれども
でも決して音楽のコンクールように美術のコンクールの方が楽しいというわけではあり
ません
私は自分の絵があまり上手ではないことをよく知っていました
なので技術を上げるために一時的
d 声楽を分
という理
東京藝術大学という有名な美術2学校に行くための予備校に帰った時期があります
それまで
へというのは例えば岡本太郎のようにチェーンに書くものとばかり思っていましたが
それは違いました
絵は苦しむ送る人
舞島1まず石膏像を絶賛2
知力道から簡単というわけではありませんかなり近くで難しい
そして他にもモチーフを見てアイデアを形にしたり
色サイズが後世の練習をしたりします
ここから色が増えることでしたらないと申しますたださせをするだけではなく技術を
高めるためのトレーニングが必要でした
やっぱり基礎がきちんとできていなくては縁と音楽にしよう
説得力のある表現はできません
話の代わり少し前の話になります
私にとって大きな転換点となるか今の北二つありました
ん
一つは中村キースヘリング美術館国際コンクールです
キースへリングと言うかご存知ですかちょっと金爆何を見たことがある人は少なくない
はずです
31歳の時にリーズでなくなっていう
ということはどういうことがお分かりになります
それについては後でまたお話するんですか
この画家さんの絵を主に収蔵している美術館コンクールに中学3年生とに入賞しました
ん
その絵はどんなだったかというと
とってもくらいです
授賞式が好き c 細粒講評会思いもかけない話をいただきました
ある程度予想していたこととは私にとってはとても商品があったんです
他の受賞者はいろいろ止められているのに私の番にしてあるし
小さいのいました
実はこの身について評価を待ってたぜ言われましたと
今までおめなところしかなかった私にはとても辛い経験者
でも lgbt と呼ばれるー
ニュースに記事
ティだったように
ディズティーなどのマイノリティの人たちに評価をしていただけたということは私に
とって貴重な経験になりました
ここでわかったことがあります
いったい私はどうしてはそんなに甘くないん
今君にたくさん受賞石です受賞させていただくことができたのでしょうか
それは自分らしさがあったからだと思います
目にしてもが口にしてもいい
自分らしさがなければそれは機会が出来レースです
または機械でもできるうえになります
自分らしさを求めていくことが今9いるだけではなく様々な面で重要だということが私
はわかりました
また
とどこのコンクールを見て私はこの会 day
もっと最優秀者を行いました
あまりう前へと私も思っていません
ただぐるぐるしている竹の枝と最初は自分でも思っていましたが
このよ私に対して言っ
いろんな服を選んでくれました
チャン島
1週間の虜横さえも航空日食事
全て無効がが2つしてくるものとノートパソコン1台という副賞がついてきたんです
私にとってこれ以上なく大きなものになりました
そしてその虜旅行では私はたくさんいろんな刺激を受けました
例えばこの植物なんだかわかりますかん
トリコに配転植物といってすぐにねそう出来るものっ
とはあまり言えないかもしれないですがこそ抜きです
故障なんて日本ではほぼ入っていません
でもよく使っているものではあるのでそれが本当に入っているのを見ることは私にとっ
てすごい音だけでした
またトルコの自然は日本とは全く違ったものです
そして文化の全く違ったものです
カッパドキアに行ったときに私はこの光景を見たんですよ
この目玉のお守りがいっぱいでは下がっていて最初は気持ち悪いと思う
この守りはあ
酒盗良きの守りと言われていますナザールボンジュというものです
こんなにたくさん入っパイプが下がっているととても綺麗に見えてくると思いませんか
日本上なかなかできない体験を取りこれたくさんさせていただきましたん
現在は主にそのパソコンを使ってこんなデザインをしたりしています
私にとって今まで美術と音楽というものはそれぞれ別の趣味だったんですよ
ある時こんなことを言いました
爆ねそ最低オーケストラでチラシ今まで作ってきているけれどどうもなかなか良いもの
がないということです
お前はできるならやってみないかスーパーに言われて
一番左にある定期演奏会の上を必死にワードで作ってみたのが始まりです
ただ
自分としてはただチラシを黒くすればそんなリプロっぽくなるだろうという安直な
考えることに作った催したので遊び見てみてちょっと後悔しました
なのでもっといいものを作りたいと自分なりに色々と調べた結果
アドミ車柄している photoshop や illustrator を使うこと
によってより大きな表現が可能になることをしました
なので私は必死にそれが2つのソフトの研究をして
なんとかすでにも降格しある程度機能を使えるようになりました
ん
そのような状態で作ったのが真ん中の散らすと右のチラシです
高校に入ってからはこのようにアブネル最低や収集農家フィールドのオーケストラの
印刷物目剤をしています
今度は自分だけの自由ではなくこういう雰囲気の家だからとか見て分かりやすいような
文字の大きさと配置と配色
セイビンの中で私だしたをいかにして発揮するかといえば模索せる面白いされるんです
降りていたずらをしているような自分になりながら楽しんで作ることができます
もっと良い面とを作るにはもっと加須今のスキル分けなければとか
どんどん興味の方向は広がっていきますしまた二部で勉強したいことがホット見えてき
ます
そして何よりいろんな人と打ち合わせをしたり感謝の言葉を言っていただくことでまた
私のつながりを増えていたんです
音楽と美術の両方私は学んで実勢したことで
2つが繋がっているという楽しいをしました
似ているようなところもあれば全く違うところごはんなに
切っても切れない関わりがあることはやればやるほどわかってくるんです
オペラミュージカル演劇や舞台美術も興味があります
広告デザインをもっとしてみたくなりました
またデジタル画像を使うことからインターネットよりも少し詳しくなりまたソフトの
開発にも少し詳しくなってきたのでプログラミングなどをやっています
また様々な方面に試合ができ小さな私が
苦しんでいたように昔のように寂しい思いをすることもなく
人とコミュニケーションのすることができるようになりました
そしてコミュニケーションすることが楽しくなったのです
また日本という社会狭い頃なので新しく知り合ったと思った人が結局
友達の友達ということもかなり増えてきました
今までした事は私はいい
私が今までしてきたことは決して無駄ではなく
今まで偉人
店内に今までの事が全てつながっているということが分かりました
超ここでお話ししたことでまた新しい出会いがありました
私の醤油また具体的な目標が決まっておらず
んです
いろいろなことをやっていて迷ってしまうなかなかどれを選べばいいのかわからない
です
でもこうして今までの自分について
一生あらためて振り替えつの勇気会でした
私には高校生活はまだ1年弱残されています
小広げながら音楽と美術の両方を生かせる
私だし1を選んでいきたいとおもいます
なかなかミスの多い喋り方になってしまいました今日はこのような素晴らしい機会を
与えていただきありがとうございました
はぁ
goo
rar
頑張って